I don't know I don't tell myself I made
it I don't tell myself I'm successful I
tell myself I'm hungry and I want to
keep it on so music became like my like
passion my vehicle for you know me what
I was you know driven to do I meet fans
it like it's been like 25 shows and
that's crazy but it's like you could
lose that trust in an instant if you
ever broke your brand he's an American
rapper and record producer
his first major label album these things
happen hit number three on the US
Billboard 200
his single me myself and I hit number
seven on the US Billboard 100
he's G easy and here's my take on a top
ten rules of success rule number one is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always guys as you're watching
the videos if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well also as you are writing
something down it's much more likely to
stick in your head to enjoy
so hard and then when you think you're
going hard go harder like that's really
is its hustle you know I mean there's
nothing in life that you can't you can't
put enough work in every single day and
not get better at you know what I mean
like if you want to be good at something
you know I mean like you can't just like
not like do it every day and not get
better this is nice with music which
makes learning how to play an instrument
so if you spend your time practicing
your craft like you know that's really
it just you know because nowadays like
with the internet everything is so
accessible and you know everybody in the
world is a rapper you know I mean
everybody's putting music out so it's
like how do you stand out quality is
always going to matter but also being
different you can't try to be different
I mean but you gotta be yourself whole
take credit for your success you gotta
have a great team so having the right
people around you prize prize another
night of turnout is just be myself and I
both were solid workers but also just
positive influences for you you know any
crew that inspires you will bring good
energy every day that and do you know
hard-working dedication just cause I can
see I just need privacy plus a whole lot
of Shri Mata Tata see is these made to
do men get along with their China Sea
and you got to have that ability to kind
of self criticism you know I mean and
and learning and being willing to you
know take a step back and
you know learn more and not just feel
like I mean a lot of times you know it's
so many artists I just feel like I'm the
hottest why not you know I mean why am I
not doing arenas right now why why am I
not you know I mean out of my big state
get swept on how did I you know me
whatever but you really just got to
follow Buster's paying dues and he's
taking that time and just putting the
work in
what does he expect one especially in
the music career regular people we know
everything I finished college I'm like
I've been just you know living off music
and you got all this free time but it's
on you to like do I got it I really got
to be in studio today now I just go to
Google homing is not just like be
everywhere not just like you know do it
it's just like you know just just focus
because at the end of the day like when
that work is done you can see the result
like it takes you places so for me it
was really like I want to zero in and
just focus and for me that was giving it
everything I mean success I don't I
don't think it's something you can I
don't I don't think you can you know
describe successes you know it's
actually the mean different things to
different people and there's different
levels of success I'd say we're starting
to enjoy success now I bought my mom a
brand new car for a birthday
I was definitely a dream come true to me
that was a level of success but then you
look at jay-z you know I'm saying he'll
tell you a billion is success and we
make it to a beat or whatever you know
understand like he's way way way up
there in the stratosphere so this is
just like I don't know I don't tell
myself I made it I don't tell myself I'm
successful I tell myself I'm hungry and
I want to keep it on I mean I grew up
within hip-hop culture you know that's
what I was immersed in because we used
like that's what I was surrounded by so
naturally that's you know what I
gravitate gravitated towards I mean if I
grew up somewhere else maybe I would
have wanted to play guitar like you know
sing folk songs or something
but that was just naturally what I
gravitated to because that was well
founded by that was my world
I don't know I was in the music you know
some kids were in the basketball I
wasn't very good so you know music was
like I wasn't just like he killed you
know I don't know play video games is
sat on computer all day doing nothing
just I mean I was like a driven kid you
know I mean so music became like my like
passion my vehicle for you know me what
I was you know driven to do and
naturally it was without surrounded by I
think a lot of people kind of get it
like my stuff like I feel like I could
only get my music into the right persons
hands or something like that that my
life would change instantly and I just I
don't think we live in that day and age
anymore you had a man aside about
waiting to be discovered you got to
discover yourself and build your own
following and make it happen
I mean fans it like it's been like 25
shows and that's crazy but it's like you
could lose that trust in an instant if
you ever broke your brand yeah if you
ever broke your identity and what you
stand for and that's why it's like it
doesn't matter how tired I am from you
know that day schedule or the shows the
night before like 10 shows in a row
without an off day or whatever like if
I'm traveling to a city if I have an
event if I'm talking to people whatever
like they don't care about what happened
last night in Orlando they they came
here you know me for the show and the
walls tonight and you have to give it
your all
and always be you and never slack
because it's like they don't yeah they
don't care what you're going like so you
gotta always like you know and that is
the same thing it's like with an album
or a song or even like a feature verse
or something like that it's like second
you break that gonna mean and then black
is like when you let people down and you
start to lose that brand loyalty of like
you know if you if you were like a
coca-cola person and some like your
enemy and like you went to the store you
bought a coke and it started tasting
funny and it just dropped off you're not
amazing just you wouldn't be a comfort
anymore
I'm a little touchy you know I mean so
like are you like your lumber I'm gonna
jump over to the side it's the same
thing it's like enough for no reason
because you'd stop trusting that coke
was going to be what you rely on it yeah
[ __ ] is always having a strong sense
itself and I having that confidence you
know whatever environment you're in
you know whether good or bad is just you
know knowing who you are never reaching
the child you know impress anybody or be
something you're not and just feel
comfortable in your own skin and that's
not always easy but it's all a process
is responding yourself through the
journey of life I think the most
beautiful part about life is finding
what you love to do and finding your
place in it and finding a way to make
that a reality whether you love to paint
or to make music or to play sports or
you know write whatever it is that you
love to do in life or whatever it is
that you love to live or the people you
like to be around and finding ways to
make that a reality like I fell in love
with hip-hop when I was real little and
I started writing raps and making beats
and I was like this is what I love to
spend my time doing I want to find a way
to make that a reality and get to travel
the world and get to
you know live the way I want to to share
that with people
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this really because Razvan asked me
to because there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know what a gez say
that has the biggest impact on you what
lesson are you going to take the most
from this video and immediately apply
somehow to your life or business leave
it down in the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick share with you our
sheets thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
making those awesome tripping pictures
and sharing them with me I really really
really appreciate your support so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I just think music is changing in terms
of the gatekeepers and the power that be
the powers that be and I feel like it's
in a more democratic time it's like the
power is in the musicians hands and in
the fans and I mean they choose you know
what what matters what's relevant what
sells what you know it's not so much
like the old powers the old gatekeepers
who could just shove something down your
throat it's like you know you see less
and less superstars and more and more
organically grown you know artists like
myself who are just you know just doing
something a little different you know I
mean bending genres and don't
necessarily fit with business like
format or walls of you know whatever
kind of doing their own thing and
finding an audience and in growing it
organically and making it happen
[Music]